- What we're seeing in Beijing here
is concern that Chinese authorities
may not be able to get
COVID cases under control.
In the Chinese capital,
things have actually
been relatively normal
for most of the past two years.
But now with the Omicron
variant spreading so quickly
across China, and threatening the capital,
the mood has changed.
(pensive music)
And I'm now here at a
supermarket in Beijing
where they've really
been stocking up quickly
to make sure that shelves are full
of fruits, vegetables, meats
and other goods and over the weekend,
we saw a lot of panic buying here
as people were stockpiling
and hoarding goods.
People in Beijing were looking at Shanghai
and the lockdown there that has persisted
for more than a month already
and worried about their
own supplies of vegetables.
And so people have been basically filling
their shopping baskets with
as much as they could get.
(resident speaking in foreign language)
- If we do get cases spreading in China,
that is gonna threaten the economy,
for the global economy too, of course.
China's the world's
second-largest economy.
This is a country that is
deeply tied to the West.
It may have to keep its borders closed
for many more months to
come, perhaps even years,
and that's gonna have an impact both
on expatriates and multinationals
doing business in China,
as well as trading partners of China.
So the question is really how
much China's gonna be able
to do to prop up its economy this year,
a year in which stability
is gonna be paramount
as Xi Jinping, the leader,
seeks to secure a third term in power.
(pensive music)